You're not dying.
What did you just say?
Stella, you're cured.
So, what are you gonna do with the first day of the rest of your life?
I'll get a job.
How are you planning on doing that?
The same way that every millennial with a funky haircut and no college education does.
I will be a barista.
It's Tymothi with an "i".
Got it.
Actually, the "i" is at the end.
Seriously?
We didn't have a future.
But now we do, and I want us to be honest with each other about who we are.
Tell me one good reason why I shouldn't fire you.
I have cancer.
Is that true?
Not the cancer part.
The cancer part was the only part.
I used to have all the answers but now, I don't know anything at all.
You beat certain death.
I think you can figure out how to handle uncertain life.
So, there it was,...
...the end of my cancer movie, but the beginning of my life sentence,...
...which was full of promise.
For the first time since I found out I wasn't dying, I was truly happy to be alive.